who's going to pay for this stuff and  that is a very fair point what all of us  should know  is that over the last 25 years there has  been a massive transfer of wealth in  this country from you  to the top one-tenth of one percent in  other words the middle class has shrunk  and trillions of dollars have gone to  the top one tenth of one percent  do you think it's inappropriate to ask  those people to stop paying their fair  share of taxes so we can adequately fund  medicaid and making public colleges and  universities tuition-free is that an  unfair thing to ask  i don't think it's an unfair thing to  ask  [Applause]  the workers  [Applause]  bernie sanders visibly perplexed that's  just the best isn't it she still has no  idea that she voted for the wrong person  based on what she wants to see happen